hey guys you asked for it so you got
here's our first buzu tutorial and we're
going to show you guys how to take a
nodal pan and buzu and bring that in
after effects so for this tutorial I'm
going to show you how about 99% of buzu
shots actually work it's a very easy
program and you can pretty much go from
your footage and into After Effects in
about 5 steps now it's important to know
who's you does two types of tracking the
first is the nodal pan basically a nodal
pan is where you're stationary and
you're just panning the camera around
there's no actual 3d movement the second
is a free move and a free move is where
the camera is actually moving in 3d
space as if you're walking with the
camera there's a couple things you want
to consider before shooting a shot
you're going to track the first is
making sure that you have a high shutter
speed now it doesn't have to be extreme
but about 1 over 60 to 1 over 120 is
usually decent for tracking you don't
want too much motion blur because it can
kind of screw things up sometimes as you
can see here we're going to be starting
with a shot from angry birds or Niko
goes over to look at some barrels and if
you look here there's a slight zoom in
the shot but Buju we'll handle that just
fine that's why it's so great so if
you're on a Mac you can use MOV files
just fine but if you're on a PC you
might want to consider bringing your
file in as an image sequence because it
tends to work a little bit better
sometimes it crashes if you bring in
video files so make sure you're in task
view for this to change it just go to
the tab on the left side of the screen
and change it from toolbox to task view
it gives you the options you'll need to
complete this tutorial
so in buzu you're going to go to import
sequence find your footage somewhere
around here there it is open that up so
since we'll be doing a nodal pan you'll
go to the track type and select nodal
pan not free move but nodal pan so the
biggest thing that you want to watch out
for in bushu is making sure that your
frame eights are consistent between your
footage the booze you file and After
Effects you want to be checking that as
you go through this process and since
there's a slight zoom in the shot we
have to double click on focal length and
we go to your range drop-down and change
it from constant to varying pretty much
everything from this point is automated
so just double click on feature tracking
and hit start and it will go and it will
track your shot you'll see all these
cool little dots show up on your screen
how to now go grab a soda or something
I'm going to fast forward through the
rest of this awesome it's done that was
fast
so what Buju has done here is basically
done about a billion automatic point
trackers for us which will now use to
generate our camera data doing this is
the easiest part just go over and double
click on camera solves make sure
optimize camera smoothness is checked
and hit ok looks like this is going to
take oh no it's already done all you
have to do from this point is export
them and bring them into After Effects
so as I said earlier the frame rates you
have to watch out for and the biggest
problem with bushu is that sometimes it
glitches out on all the time it glitches
out and screws up your frame rate before
you export it so under cameras go to
camera one drop that down and open your
sequence double click on that and reset
your frame rate back to whatever it was
supposed to be at and hit OK now you're
ready to export it go to export select
export camera solve and you see a bunch
of options here make sure you have a
file path set up for your file
and make sure After Effects MA file is
selected this is what After Effects
reads and under your scene scale turn
that to about a thousand what this does
is makes it so that when you bring it
into After Effects you don't have to
make extreme adjustments to the scale of
your files boom done that's it
exporting exporting exporting exporting
all right now go open up After Effects
and once that's open find the files that
were created in the finder the MA file
in your footage and drag those into the
projects window the dot ma file will
create a composition for you that you
can use so open the composition up and
as you see here all those little
tracking markers are imported into After
Effects as well for your reference and
the first thing you want to make sure
you do is check the framerate see even
it changes here so put that back to
whatever you were working in hit OK and
once the frame rates changed all you
have to do drag your footage into the
comp and it should look perfect if it
doesn't look perfect you didn't follow
the instructions so in order to get your
files to move with the footage they need
to be 3d layers so to test that out
create something or drag something in
than image whatever and turn the 3d mode
on for it now you don't see it at first
but that's because the position is
exactly at the camera's position so it's
just the z-depth a little bit to push it
deeper into the shot
once it's at a decent spot you can see
it you're pretty much good to go
you might want to preview it to make
sure everything is working and yeah take
a look as you can see here it is ready
to go all you have to do from this point
is just drop your footage in there and
it will match the shot perfectly usually
we use Buju when we have to drop bigger
things into the shot such as a lot of
fake objects it's good format paintings
when you have to replace the background
or add two elements in the shot it's
also good for when you know you're going
to have a ton of bullet hits and other
effects in the shot as well if you just
have like one little bullet hit or
something you want to track it's best to
either use the point tracker or Moka so
that's about it I hope you guys learned
something and enjoyed that in the next
tutorial we're going to cover how to do
free moves and bring them also into
other programs such as 3d studio max if
you have any questions it is up on
Twitter or take a look at the manual
never hurts laters
[Music]